your mom I mean last week we the camera  panned to her and she's in tears how is  she reacting to you going through all  this and how is she supporting you my  mom is the most beautiful and strong  human being I have ever known and no  matter what has happened in life her  strength and her support has never once  waited and and she she is so kind she's  there every single day during rehearsal  she said Derek will tell you she sits on  the little couch running Australia Zoo  cuz we're still running Australia Zoo  back at home so she's running the zoo  but she still with me in rehearsals and  you know it that means everything and  and as a family we ac/dc that the song  that we we did that night it was it was  a beautiful song and it meant a lot to  us as a family because it did remind us  of dad and so through this whole journey  we're always thinking of him and just  making sure that his legacy and message  lives on in us